omar rode his boat for a total of 50
miles over the past five days and he
rode the same amount each day
how many miles did omar row his boat
each day
so let's just visualize what's going on
he's able to travel 50 miles so let's
make a this let's say this line
represents the 50 miles that he travels
so this whole distance right over here
is 50 miles
50 miles and he does it they tell us
that he does it over five days and that
each day he does the same amount so this
50 miles is if you were to add together
all of what he did over the five days
and so if you want to know how much he
did each day you essentially want to
divide this 50 miles into five equal
sections and the length of each of those
sections is the amount he did each day
so if we just visualize it so that's one
section second section
third section fourth and fifth section
and actually i didn't it should look a
little bit more equal than that first
second
and that's not going to let's see first
third
fourth and fifth and you don't have to
actually do this but this is just to
help visualize so essentially we want to
figure out what is one of these
distances and as you can see visually
that this is really just taking our 50
miles and dividing it into five equal
chunks so we're essentially just taking
so we're just we're just taking 50
we're just going to take 50 and we're
going to divide by 5. so 50 divided by 5
is going to be equal to
10.
so if he goes 50 miles over 5 days you
divide by the five days he goes 10 miles
10 miles each day and we're done